[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in brady quinn the fox
college football analyst former nfl
notre dame quarterback let me start with
that topic what do you make of this
whole situation and what's the end game
in green bay brady
well in regards to devante adams i mean
i think they'll eventually get a deal
done with him
uh he's too good of a player to let go
and for the reasons you just mentioned
i mean i i went through in the nfl you
know i remember having guys like braylon
edwards and kellen winslow who would
come off pro bowl seasons
and then they were traded away and then
how you have to start over as a young
quarterback in the league and trying to
get younger guys up to speed
it's it's hard to do i mean it's hard
enough to do your job
at a young age or if you're jordan
jordan jordan love shoes in this case
let alone try to get other younger guys
to step up into that role
so um i think eventually they'll find a
way of getting something done
with davonte adams but as far as aaron
rodgers goes
i mean look your guest is as good as
mine
i i still believe he'll come back and
play i think he loves football too much
and
i don't think he wants to sit out a year
and let the packers see what the future
looks like
but there's no doubt and obviously his
time in green bay is
is coming to an end if not relatively
soon after the season
i had mentioned that i think the impact
of tom brady going to tampa
can not be overstated because now you
have a lot of quarterbacks
who look at that situation and go why
can't i have a seat at the table
why can't i help pick the roster why
can't i
be in there with everybody else making
decisions there
even helping with uh draft picks or at
least they bounce things off you
i think that's where russell wilson was
so frustrated
desean watson wanted out of texas
because he
you know the texans because he didn't
get a chance to have a say in who was
going to be his coach
i just and now aaron rodgers and there's
a report that aaron rodgers
wants to have a similar path that tom
brady had and maybe he gets out of his
contract earlier with green bay
i mean these quarterbacks want to be
heard
well and i think they're being
compensated to a point now where
you know i think aaron rodgers
experience being a minority owner within
the milwaukee bucks probably sheds some
light on
how another professional league does it
and when you look at now the fact that
the bucks are the defending champs
the way they built around giannis and i
know there was a lot of talk and
concern was drew holiday going to be
enough they were they could be able to
do it
uh in the end you know they did and i
think him being a minority owner
probably
shed some light on how that league
operates how that organization operates
and he's
scratched his head going hold on a
second i'm the league mvp
and and you guys can't bring me in on
some of these decisions
because i mean if you think about it too
in basketball you can have a superstar
who can be isolated
or do what giannis did in the nba finals
and absolutely dominate and take over
as a quarterback i mean they should be
getting
your opinion on what you think of some
guys they're thinking about bringing in
because it impacts your ability to
execute and do your
job more so than any other player on the
field
or in any other sport and so it actually
makes a lot of sense and when you
factor in how much you're compensating
quarterbacks yeah
they they should play a role probably in
some of these decisions i'm not saying
they're ultimately making the decision
in the end because i don't know if
that's a good principle to set for any
organization any company but at the end
of the day they're a huge influence and
their
ability you know their output is going
to be greatly impacted by whoever they
bring
in now you played the position played at
notre dame played in the nfl but if you
were going to describe aaron rodgers
on the field like how would you if
somebody didn't see aaron rodgers and
you're going to tell them about
the greatness of aaron rodgers how would
you describe that
as far as a player his demeanor just
playing ability
well quarterback ability whatever comes
under that umbrella
quarterback ability i would say he makes
the game look so easy
i mean i i i really i feel like when you
watch quarterbacks play
um some some when they make it look as
easy as he does and obviously the tom
brady's the patrick holmes fall in that
category
it's almost like he's an artist like the
way he goes around and plays the
position
he makes the look easy he makes
ridiculously hard throws
look easy and even the small things like
how he navigates the pocket
and buys time like he's not the most
athletic guy
but he's sudden enough and he knows how
to move
subtly just enough to be able to make a
guy miss or
make a rusher kind of commit inside and
he kind of rolls out around him i mean
he just
he is he really is an artist with the
way he plays the position it's
it's it's hard to really put that into
words because between his arm talent
that's one thing
but then it's just the way he moves and
the way he sees the field and
manipulates the defense
that's the fun part about watching him
for me is he
many times knows where he's already
going with the football then it's just a
game of how he's going to manipulate
everyone else to do what he wants to do
and really he's out there playing you
know chess not checkers
you can catch brady quinn along with bob
stoops reggie bush matt leinart and rob
stone the
big noon kickoff saturdays this fall at
10 a.m eastern on
fox speaking of college football looks
like it's not if but when
it's going to be oklahoma and texas
going to the sec the announcement
could come as early as next week what do
you make of this move
for the sec and the big 12.
well i think it's it's huge for the sec
but i don't even know so much if it's
about
the sec more more than it's about texas
and oklahoma
doing what they feel like is in their
best interest moving forward and
when i say that i mean from a monetary
standpoint right i think we
you know everyone went through last year
i think pretty much every school ran a
deficit
and they're probably now looking forward
and saying we have to look out for our
own best interests we we can't
worry about the conference we're in we
need to move to a place where we feel
like
we're going to be able to generate the
most revenue and into the best of my
knowledge the sec
tv contracts and generate the most
revenue so that revenue share
would be greater than anywhere else it
makes a little bit of sense from a you
know
geography standpoint that that would be
the conference they would join
i think if you look at the overall
culture in the southeast and just
you know the you know football the way
it's played from high school up
you know it makes a lot of sense for the
type of kids they're recruiting and
everything else
so i just i think if they're going to
make that move
that's the that's the conference you
want to be a part of but
this stuff has been in the works for a
while i think a lot of people have
talked about the whole idea of
four super conferences or whatever else
who knows what
what it's going to be it could be look
more like the nfl maybe it's only two
conferences
when it's all said and done i just think
with so much change that we saw
last year and how conferences and
schools adjusted to kovid
i think they both kind of took this
opportunity to say all right
you know if we're if we're going to look
into the future what this landscape
might look like
let's go to the place where we feel like
we can capitalize off the most of
our players can probably capitalize off
the most of an il because one thing we
haven't talked about is
you know how these players are going to
potentially be able to get a piece of
the tv money
because that's still kind of up in the
air and if again if that
tv contract's the biggest that's only
going to help you too in the way you go
about recruiting kids
you know if your pitches come to the
place where you feel like you have the
best
opportunity to earn the most in nil or
build your brand
under our brand or co-brand with texas
and oklahoma so
you know obviously it's good for the sec
it's good for probably both those two
schools but
it's going to hurt the big 12. and i'm
not really sure what's going to be left
of the big 12
if those two schools leave yeah i don't
know how
they can continue to exist it feels like
it's every school for themselves right
now
well i was wondering with name image and
likeness you going to notre dame
would would have it have impacted your
decision
if somebody said you can make a million
dollars
come be the quarterback at alabama as
opposed to
going to notre dame and you know someone
asked me that question last night
at the big ten media day and it's it's
so hard to answer that because i think
the easy answer is yes
but i'd like to think that i wouldn't
make a short-term decision
um that would ultimately impact impact
my future
now granted if you're talking about
alabama right now as dominant as they
are and everything else yeah because you
want to go play you want to go win a
national championship and if there's
going to be a lot of extra money that
comes alongside that
so be it um but i i do like
i'm one of those people i came back i
wanted to graduate i wanted to get my
degree that was important to me
that would definitely play a factor in
all of it because because i do think
if you're purely making about what you
can generate at nil
then you're probably focused on the
wrong thing and and i know that sounds
probably hypocritical
because of what i just said but the
reality is it's great if you can you can
earn a million bucks because
one of the side conversations from that
was well how motivated is that player
going to be once they get a million
dollars
are they going to feel like they're a
paid man are they going to feel like
they don't need to i mean
my personal belief is you know once once
you get a million dollars you want to
have two
once you have two you want four once you
have 41.8 like that's kind of how it
works and so i
i tend to believe people tend to be more
motivated when they're they're paid a
good amount of money
i just think the sticky situation
becomes you know between practice and
then nil responsibilities for marketing
and so forth
where does school even come into factor
like where does it come into play
like if i've got a marketing appearance
where i'm going to go make a hundred
thousand dollars and i'm going to
do the shoot or if i'm going to go to my
economics class
i mean is that a let's hard decision
and then i was thinking about this like
my mind wandered to
like well what's the professor going to
say because obviously you got to play
you got to perform and then you got to
be eligible to be able to do those two
things
and so i don't know maybe you got some
professors who are trying to teach these
kids a world lesson saying look
i'm not i'm not saying i'm on the take
but i could probably help you out a
little bit here and there
if you push something money my way well
this is what i've maintained brady
i think that if you have kids who want
to go to college
and you have name image and likeness and
there's money involved
why don't you steer them towards
classes that actually help you in
business in real estate in
in you know investing sports marketing
sports management
you don't need to take the history of
mesopotamia as i did at the university
of dayton
like it doesn't it doesn't it helps you
in trivial pursuit once every five years
but these are things that are going to
that way we get
rid of this hey you're a student athlete
you got to take these
these courses here why not if you're
going to treat them as
professionals pay them as professionals
then
why don't you have a curriculum that
that would you know kind of steer them
towards that
i think you'd be you'd be surprised to
find most universities are starting to
implement things of that nature they
really are you know i was just at notre
dame my foundation has a program that's
going on right now out there for
veterans
and just talking about it like they
they're prepared for this and they're
preparing their players for this
you know one of the things you could
hear at the big ten media days and pat
fitzgerald talked about this was just
how you know the schools want to be
there to reinforce and help them make
the best decision
for them with their parents or whoever
that support system is
so i think the schools are much more
cognizant of that
than you might realize i think you know
notre dame's done a good job of bringing
back former players who are in
different you know careers at this kind
you know kind of point in time and
telling them
kind of helping with helping them with
that transition so
that's that's probably more common than
i think you realize at this point
and i do think universities are going to
have to start looking at
like what what you need to start taking
in order to get your actual degree
and and and do away with some of the
other stuff that's out there and even
though i do think it's good for
enriching your
general knowledge and you know you know
understanding how to think to your point
i don't know that all courses are
relevant for these these
players and what they're being asked to
do i'll leave you with this
should the uh nfl covet protocols result
in forbid
forfeitures of games and paychecks
gosh this is such a i mean
my issue with this is is is you know
we've seen in other professional leagues
whether it's the pga or the nba
even if you're vaccinated and you test
positive you're still going to miss time
and so the only thing that i think that
they're incentivizing players
to get vaccinated not because they're
not going to get code because they still
can
and it's obviously going to reduce your
symptoms and chances of death etc
but you know they're not at the risk
group anyway it's really about the fact
that if they're all vaccinated
then they can stop testing and then it's
an afterthought right like that's what
this is about
because the protocols are different for
those who are vaccinated versus those
who aren't
and so if you if you got everyone
vaccinated we can stop testing
or at least not test quite as frequently
and we don't have to worry about whether
or not a guy's positive because
he very well might be but if he's
vaccinated you feel better about your
chances of him not spreading it or not
having symptoms
and you might not find out until that
next test comes whenever that is i think
it's
maybe once a week or however often it is
now but
that's what they're pushing them i think
to do because the nfl
obviously last year pushed through covid
and they want to keep pushing
past it you know this year they'd love
for it to be an afterthought
especially if you're gonna have full
stadiums your wife won an olympic medal
in beijing i think
uh where is that baller where where is
the medal
oh god she uh she's actually coming back
from boston
soon today i don't know if it's up there
with her parents
or if she's got like in a closet
somewhere like neither of us
are the type where we have anything
we've ever won
like up on display and in fact in one po
at one point i think one of our i think
our middle child teagan
i think she's like three years old she
got into one of our storage boxes
and was like running around outside with
it and it wasn't until a neighbor told
us so like hey you might want to
you know might want to take this off to
make sure she doesn't like damage it or
do anything because i'm
pretty sure this is a silver medal from
the 2008 olympics
and it was so i mean we just that's just
not how
alicia is she's very humble but i'm sure
our daughters will dress up in all her
uh
all her medals and awards do they know
what you do your kids know what you guys
did
no they have no clue i mean i try to
show them especially because our eldest
sloane
is almost five and she's kind of into
gymnastics i try to show her clips of
mom
and she's still trying to understand why
mom can't do what she did back
what is that now almost 14 years ago
she's
she's trying to put that together still
but she doesn't realize like
she has a lot of questions still and
still trying to put it all together but
they have no idea
uh great to talk to you about i
appreciate your time i know you had a
busy schedule
thanks for working this in any anytime i
always love being on
that's uh brady quinn fox college
football
analyst and former nfl notre dame
quarterback